first came the atom named after opel's
founder now the automaker has christened
a car after adam opel's elden's son the
carl is completely new as opal's carson
engenheister explains
we have victors
he says they were given the job of
designing a sub-compact and began making
sketches freehand drawings
they tried to find themes for the side
the front the rear
once they had down on paper what they
wanted to transform into three
dimensions a long process began which
led to the final product
and here it is the carl which is typical
opal traits
for less than 10 000 euros buyers get a
four-door model that's 3.68 meters in
length with room for five the carl which
will be marketed as the vauxhall viva in
the uk is a true city car to help the
vehicle fit into tiny parking spaces
overhangs have been kept to a minimum
stefan says that's a challenge for the
designers but it's fun to work together
with the engineers they want the car to
take up little space so it must be small
but the interior should seem bigger than
the car really is that's not easy but
it's fun to work on the whole package
opel's successful corsa super mini has
been on the road for 33 years
in 2012 it was joined by the little opal
adam
the carl is the latest addition to the
club and is opal's entry-level city car
but that doesn't mean they've cut
corners
says that even if it's cheap they wanted
the car to make a good impression with
its german engineering and precision the
carl's appearance should leave no doubt
that it's made in germany art says it's
a full-fledged five-seater with a
full-fledged interior it has everything
its larger sister models have starting
with the intellilink radio
so the carl isn't inferior when it comes
to infotainment either and safety
features like a lane departure warning
system and cruise control with a speed
limiter are also available as extras
the coral is fitted with the one liter
three cylinder gas engine used in the
corsa and atom but when it comes to
design the carl goes its own way
the opel designer says the very dynamic
front and headlights draw the eye
towards the vehicle side here you find
the typical sickle shaped characteristic
of opal it's supported by these very
dynamic lines up here which make the car
look even more compact and give it its
own unique character
unlike the two-door atom the coral is a
four-door creating 940 liters of trunk
space was a challenge for the designers
giving the cars small dimensions
stefan notes that they might have to
shorten the seats or arrange things
differently than they would in a larger
car center consoles or storage
compartments might be closer together
than they are in the insignia or astra
yet it works
he's 1.76 meters tall and with the right
adjustments can sit comfortably in the
driver's seat or in the back
the coral has a manual 5-speed
transmission our test car boasts the
most expensive trim package and costs
upwards of thirteen thousand euros in
germany opel says that this little car
also uses little fuel
still stiff on stresses that the carl is
a four-door model with seating for five
that makes it a more family-friendly and
more of an all-rounder than the atom
which targets a younger and more
feminine segment
here opel's targeting older more
conservative buyers who have to mine
their money more
those looking for a lifestyle car will
likely opt for the atom the corsa is a
somewhat larger more complete vehicle
with a choice of several body styles and
variants
the coral is opal's entry-level model
but nonetheless very complete
starting this summer with the coral the
atom and the corsa in its stable opal
will boast the strongest lineup of super
minis in its history and among the
latest on the market
audi debuted its compact suv q3 in the
autumn of 2011. now the german car maker
has given its niche offering a refresh
and refined the performance version the
rs q3
the rs exhaust system has a switchable
flap to give the five-cylinder engines
unmistakable sound even greater volume
says the new audi rs q3 may burn a hole
in the buyer's pocket but it's a lot of
car for the cash 250 kilowatts of power
to push it from zero to 100 kilometers
per hour in just 4.8 seconds the new
grille stands out it stretches from
headlight to headlight and the air
intake set it apart as well
the front looks nice and beefy and the
rs badging on the front rear and sides
is just as standard as the led head and
tail lights
the roof spoiler is larger than on the
regular q3s
stresses the performance has been
enhanced to 250 kilowatts with 450
newton meters of torque 30 more than its
predecessor on both counts at the same
time fuel consumption has been cut to
some 198 grams of co2 per kilometer that
amounts to a combined rate of 8.4 liters
per 100 kilometers nearly half a liter
less and the five cylinder engine is now
compliant with the eu6 emission standard
optional with the standard rs sports
chassis are adaptive dampers the
steering is sports car tight and the
standard audi drive select offers
comfort auto and dynamic modes the 250
kilometer an hour top speed is limited
electronically
the rsq3's design is refreshed right to
the tail lights with dynamic turn
signals pointing the way the driver
wants to go
the rsq3's interior also reflects the
price tag although sports seats are
optional the rs logos and carbon fiber
components set the rs apart from its
regular q3 brother
reinhardt can spot the audi rs q3 from a
distance not only by its looks but more
by its sound
he says the throaty sound is typical for
a powerful five-cylinder engine and it's
fun to drive audi may rate fuel
consumption at an average of 8.4 liters
but it came out closer to 10 in our test
in germany the rsq3 starts at 56 600
euros reynold sums up
no other car of this class offers 250
kilowatts he had lots of fun in the rsq3
not just making it roar but making it go
to the max this kind of power comes at a
price of course not just with a purchase
but with a running cost as well
bmw is rolling out its latest
convertible just in time for spring the
new 2 series rag top is 7.2 centimeters
longer than its predecessor otherwise
its proportions are typically bmw with a
long hood and wheelbase and broad toe
at the touch of a button the soft top
opens and shuts in just 20 seconds even
at speeds of up to 50 kilometers an hour
the top of the line version is the bmw
all-wheel drive m235i x drive with a 240
kilowatt engine
fiat's giving its family minivan the
doblo a new look the headlights are
better positioned to prevent cracks from
flying grit and clumsy parkers the
streamlining has been improved too but
the car is still available in two
lengths allowing customers to configure
it into a seven seater with room for
four thousand liters of luggage
prices start at seventeen
800 euros for the 70 kilowatt basic
model with a gasoline engine and short
wheelbase a top flight longer 99
kilowatt doblo sells for nearly 25 000
euros
the porsche moves peacefully through the
snow on a tranquil winter's day
quiet isn't something most people
associate with the famed german sports
car
roaring engines and a thirst for fuel
are more likely to come to mind
our tester chris question says the
silence is made possible by an electric
motor under the hood this vehicle was
porsche's first plug-in hybrid
though there are now hybrid cayennes and
918 spider super sports cars the
panamera was porsche's first plug-in
hybrid the luxury sedan requires four
hours to recharge its batteries but that
power supply entails a sacrifice of
nearly a third of the panamera's 435
liter trunk space
the sc hybrid system output is high
acceleration is rapid and the sedan has
a top speed of 270 kilometers an hour
just what you'd expect from a porsche
but what's unexpected is the car's low
fuel consumption porsche says it needs
just 3.1 liters to go 100 clicks on the
road consumption is slightly higher but
it's still possible to achieve great
fuel efficiency depending on your
driving style
to give people an incentive to drive
economically there's a graphic display
to show how long the car has run
emission free
chris says there's an all-electric
option too all you have to do is hit the
e power button and it's silent running
for the porsche panamera he adds the
range in this mode is about 35
kilometers
digital and analog indicators show the
driver which energy sources the panamera
is using in real time they display how
efficiently the car is running and when
the driver hits the gas and engages the
gasoline-powered engine
the sc hybrid looks good too porsche has
used acid green exclusively to accent
the chrome hybrid designation the brakes
match and the car's rear end features a
four barrel exhaust for the internal
combustion engine
chris says the weight of the battery
makes itself felt on the road but the
panamera still handles well and gives
you a sporty snappy drive
there's a three liter v6 under the
porsche's hood there the exclusive
hybrid color is signal orange
chris explains that the e-charge button
allows him to use the gasoline engine as
a generator to charge the batteries
while driving
it works like this the electric motor is
located between the transmission and
engine when the car is coasting a
parallel full hybrid feature introduced
by porsche for high speeds works like a
generator to convert energy into
electricity the driver doesn't notice a
thing
admittedly the reason porsche has made
the panamera a plug-in hybrid may have
more to do with increasingly stringent
emissions limits than customers desire
nevertheless porsche has made a
sophisticated vehicle equipped with
premier technology
its sensible concept in no way detracts
from the panamera's sporty image
blazing tires power on two wheels or one
and an action-packed program are the
motorad bodensee a three-day motorcycle
trade fair on lake constance that drew
some 42 000 bike fans this year
nearly 300 exhibitors presented more
than 750 machines and some 50
innovations for the coming season
motorcycle expert andreas elk says
germany had a 10 increase or some 140
000 new motorcycles on the streets in
2014 with continued growth projected for
2015 he's optimistic about the coming
year
one of the trends this year is the retro
look for example the bmw 9t
its
1170cc capacity puts out 82 kilowatts it
lists for 14
700 euros in germany
a genuine retro classic is the triumph
thruxton ace 900 with a 885 cc two
cylinder engine and an output of 51
kilowatts
its 10
500 euro list price places it among the
more affordable debuts this year
a modern twist on classic italian design
comes from ducati with the scrambler it
adds a splash of color powered by a 55
kilowatt 800 cc engine with a price tag
of not quite 800 euros
at just 6 200 euros the yamaha sr 400 is
nostalgia on a budget the fairly tame 17
kilowatts are suited more for rookie
bikers
this rice burner seems to say look i've
discovered grandpa's old bike
andreas believes more young people are
rediscovering motorcycles biking is cool
again a growing proportion of the new
cycles on the streets are beginner
models attractive to the younger
generation
bikers duds have a new look as well
modern and casual with the protectors
integrated into pockets inside the jeans
as footwear the time-honored boots are
finally out and sneakers are in with
reinforced toes for protection
there's as much room as ever for
individual styles stylish but eccentric
looks and accessories have always been
all but obligatory for true bikers
veteran bikers are in their element here
people will pay a pretty penny for the
perfect sound this machine is the
priciest at the fair listing at 400 000
euros the bmw r 1200 gs boasts the only
carbon fiber frame on two wheels it's
still a prototype with a high price
reflecting the cost of development
the fastest bike at the fair is the
kawasaki ninja h2r the first series
production motorcycle with a compressor
it's available only in the racing
version
with the throttle opened wide it can
exceed 300 kilometers per hour and 50
000 euros per bike
there's a motorcycle for every taste
need and budget at the lake constance
fair
but some two-wheelers are priceless
steve gibson takes his kids noel and
jordan everywhere if not in the flesh
then emblazoned on the fuel tank
you